[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the 90th dark horse
podcast
live stream q and a segment
are we um is that my q that's your q and
then we'll come up with an a to go with
it
all right um so we um really only have
an hour today because as brett mentioned
in the last hour he's gotta go catch
a plane that's why we're doing this
early today um
so i know i got a question from the
discord
server this week and my email everything
about my computer is failing
so i i do have another one on the way um
another computer on the way
which one i will hurl this into well
trash bin i guess
um so zack says he's going to get it to
me because i can't find it anywhere so
we're going to start with a question
that apparently came in last week
at the very end and we didn't see here
we go
i cannot find anywhere online that dr
robert malone is the inventor of the
mrna vaccine
could you please direct me towards a
source that confirms his status as the
inventor of the mrna
in fact i found only different versions
of the history of the mrna with
different inventors every time which in
of itself is strange
and that involves dr malone i absolutely
trust you though
also is the mrna a discovery or an
invention
well and there's a word there missing
right like mrna yes
we we have discovered mrna um
the and i think dr malone has clarified
um that
um he invented the vaccine delivery
platform
right um and so that is that is an
invention
using discovered parts from nature and
also using some engineered things which
are
creation yeah so this is my crude
understanding but the basic idea is the
environment outside the cell is hostile
to
renegade rnas running around probably
because they are indicative of something
gone
wrong either a pathogen of some kind or
some cell has burst and random messages
are floating around
all these rna aces right so that's how
it's pronounced but
yeah all these things that cleave rna
important yep
so in any case uh the invention is the
mechanism
to convey an rna message
past the cell membrane into the cell
where the ribosomes then do the natural
thing that they do when they
find these trans uh these transcripts
and uh translate them into protein
um so anyway that's the invention i
think there are two good sources
one is dr malone's site itself in which
he covers the question
of the invention and he provides the
evidence he's got like patents and such
right exactly and papers and things
and the other is that i believe uh
why am i blanking i don't know
alexandros
morenos morenos uh has done an analysis
because there was pushback on whether or
not malone was the inventor and i
believe
that uh there's a thread on twitter it
will take some searching but
i believe he has analyzed the question
and
validated alexander morenos on twitter
or robert malone and
this is it so his site at uh rw
malonemd.com uh which
i think somewhere i'm not sure where all
it's going to be but um you say he's
going to have the
yep the the list of the papers and the
patents and such which
um yeah
reveal his place in the story all right
all right
so i don't know i don't remember how to
use this platform
uh here we go next question can you
please discuss the lipid nanoparticles
in the vaccine
as well i have heard humic and fulvic
acid is good at enveloping viruses and
not allowing them to replicate
is this a possible supplement to look at
to include in a protocol to [ __ ] the
effects of copper19 if you get it
thank you so much your work is greatly
appreciated uh well with regard to the
second part of the question
never heard of either of these don't
know anything about it yep but the first
part of the question can you please
discuss
the lipid nanoparticles in the vaccine i
can't say very much
except that my understanding having
asked the question of dr malone and
others
is that the basically every cell has
a phospholipid bilayer that delineates
the inside of the cell and
separates it from the outside of the
cell and because
it has these fats
basically by coding the mrna excuse me
the mrna ac is on again
coughing yeah by coding the mrna in
these lipids it causes the basically
globule to join and deliver the
mrna into the cell while protecting it
while it's uh in the interstitial space
from
these uh mrna aces i don't know much
more than that
um it's obviously well i read the
question as
um well no actually maybe that's right i
read it as potentially like what
what are they what's the risk um and you
know this is something that
we've we've talked about before that the
presence of the lip and nanoparticles
is an additional novel thing in these
vaccines compared to
say the adenovector virus uh adenovirus
vectored
uh vaccines um like jnj and astrazeneca
um which don't involve the lipid
nanoparticles and so we don't know
what effects they might have um but um
but it's possibly we'll have
side effects yeah it's possible uh yeah
i think there's nothing to say
except a precautionary principle says
you're doing something novel
to cells and it may have an effect yeah
all right next question
as the binary and highly political
language around vaccination took hold
i feel like some generally accepted
facts were lost in the noise
development of effective vaccines for
respiratory viruses has been a highly
challenging enterprise
this one attempted vaccines for
coronaviruses have had significant
issues with efficacy and safety
too eradication of cova 19 has fairly
weak parallels to eradication of
smallpox and polio
did positive momentum lead to an
unrealistic expectation of the vaccines
uh yes and i but i would just add the
positive momentum
was created um
by some number of forces yes and we
didn't happen in deposit of momentum i
don't think
right and i think the things that are
most troubling
are this never amounted to a policy
that had the potential to eradicate the
vaccine that was sort of left
implied i mean eliminate the the virus
so just say that again that the
vaccination policy the technology in the
vaccines
and the deploying of those vaccines
under the emergency use authorization
never as far as i can tell stood a
chance of driving
the pathogen extinct so somebody needed
to lay out
this is a stop gap because there's
another set of vaccines coming down the
pike that does have that potential
or this is going to be used in
conjunction with these other mechanisms
and together they might drive it extinct
or there needed to be an acknowledgement
hey
actually we have no intention of driving
this extinct or even if they did
let's give them the benefit of that even
if they had even if they had the
intention of driving it extinct
it didn't have the capacity and
therefore the analysis
for both the individuals and the public
health analysis is very different
than the strong implication that hey if
we can get above
70 vaccination then uh r
naught drops below one and then we're on
a path to extinction for the virus and
anybody who blocks us from getting to 70
is the obstacle to us moving on
permanently from code which was the
implication
and it just simply it can't have been
true right um that is that
that assumes no viral evolution among
other things it assumes
well it assumes no viral evolution it
assumes that places that can't be
reached by the vaccines don't exist or
somehow stop interacting with the rest
of the world
um and so it just simply
wasn't in the cards and we were supposed
to infer it
and that's the thing that is is so
disturbing and for what
we were supposed to infer that the
vaccines were the end of the pandemic
and all we needed to do was get on board
and that would happen
yeah well i think i mean i think
certainly that's the inference that was
charted out
in uh in the messaging right whether or
not you know i don't
i can't remember seeing uh someone
you know some credentialed person who's
speaking here during the pandemic as a
scientist or
or a doctor saying that but you know
probably has happened you know you need
people to say just about anything you
know some people will say just about
anything
right but i guess my point would be all
right compare
the implied but unstated
uh hey let's get to seventy percent why
hurry immunity what will that do
are not drops below one extinction is in
the offing
right that's the implication compare
that to what we've said which is hey
you're not going to get there you're
certainly not going to get there
globally
with these vaccines so at the very least
you need a composite you need people's
uh natural immunity from having been
exposed to the virus that's a
you know the fact is was a very painful
thing that all of these people got sick
and many died but the
upside is that they have immunity that's
actually robust and broad
this is not the form of immunity you
want you want because the risks are
incredible
but if you had the disease you have this
immunity but if you
were to add that immunity to
vaccine-based immunity
to medicinal therapeutic
uh immunity like ivermectin
then you might be able to especially
since ivermectin really can reach all of
the places that the vaccine can't get to
right you really could potentially have
this of course were there such a thing
as a pandemic profiteer that what might
look very frightening to them because
it means that this giant new market
which you know
is it offers an opportunity to create
new products indefinitely into the
future
that market might dry up so anyway i
don't know that there are such people
but it certainly would
fit uh the approach we've seen
pretty well yep
um i don't know that we can do anything
with this but i'll go ahead and ask it
as a social worker i was exposed to an
unknown toxin in a client's home
this led to sudden onset asthma severe
chemical sensitivity and a paralyzed
vocal
cord i've been told there is some
connection to the vagus nerve
can you please speak to any part of this
confounding problem
wow so it sounds like it's permanent um
yeah i don't know it's it's not it's not
clear from here that's awful
um there are increasingly there
are there is a recognition of
vagal involvement vagus nerve
involvement in a number of
um a number of conditions that i think
i i don't know why i don't know what
happened but i feel like the vagus nerve
is um getting sort of
renewed attention it's yeah the point
that i was learning about is just one of
the
12 cranial nerves and just you know it's
it's along with all of its
all of its associates but it seems uh
rather more sensual for a lot of uh
human things what
because it's such a serious topic i
cannot make any of the obvious puns
downstream
of the vagus nerve so we will just leave
them implied you can
write them at home as you like well i
mean i guess
one of the things that is true is that
what happens with the vagus nerve
doesn't seem to stay with the vegas
start
excellent yeah let's leave it at that
okay
um yeah do you have anything to add to
this one
no i don't know i mean obviously there's
something frightening
if in fact it was a chemical a transient
chemical exposure in a client's home and
it has resulted in this permanent
condition that's that's frightening
um but uh you know i i can't say
anything beyond it
yeah and there's just and you know part
of part of what we talk about in the
book and indeed we talk we specifically
there's a section on smells and how
smells used to
used to present um evidence that you
were near something that was dangerous
to you if you got
if you touched it and in the modern
environment some spells themselves just
smelling them
can be the toxin and this seems to be
what you're exposed to but so that is
now true that's an effect of hyper
novelty but it's also true
that the diversity of things that are
being produced in labs and
you know sold on store shelves and
brought into people's homes
is just extraordinary and almost none of
it is vetted with any kind of
uh safety measures that i at least would
like to
be seeing so actually let's uh explore
that a little bit
um the reason that
hypernovelty creates this problem is
that things that your ancestors would
have been exposed to that were very
dangerous
it's very likely that you would have a
visceral reaction of some kind very
often olfactory you would find them
disgusting smelling or
in some way would dissuade you from
interacting so when we create new
molecules that your ancestors had no
interaction with
it's arbitrary a molecule that's
dangerous to you could smell good
you know the way solvents in paint let's
say
can sometimes smell pleasant or it could
have no smell at all
and so the what we've got now is a sort
of arbitrary map between how things
smell and
what it means and the inhalation itself
brings these things in whereas smelling
a dead fish
as far as we know smelling a dead fish
isn't dangerous to you but it does cause
you not to want to do any of the things
with the dead fish that might actually
put you in jeopardy like
try to eat it right sorry just imagine
sleeping on it
right uh sleep yes any of those things
rubbing it on open wounds
emailing it to a friend good all right
all right we're there okay i think we
have exhausted that topic excellent
um what's the deal with sweating i made
a comment about sweating like a horse
because i know pigs don't sweat and
received unexpected pushback
please give complete evolutionary
history for 50 bucks love you guys
um i don't know uh so sweating and then
it's about like sweating within
particular animals and you i think you
know everyone
everyone knows that you know i don't
know
i don't know if pigs don't sweat i don't
know that um there are different
ways of dispersing heat right there are
there and mammals have a few of them
and in other other clades have have
others um
but not sweating at all isn't something
i knew
you know we know that for instance cats
and cats and dogs
um sweat out their paws um at least cats
do i think that's true of dogs as well
um and you know you can imagine if
you're covered in fur especially if
you're coming in a thick coat sweating
is not going to be
nearly as effective because part of what
it is is um
putting uh putting liquid
on the surface of your skin such that
any breeze at all
effectively um effectively brings down
your surface temperature which can help
bring down your
you know and that's the evaporation it's
the evaporation but then also what you
get
i think this is usually considered a
separate thing but it's usually in
concert with sweating
um is vasodilation
and so you know you get you basically
get your
your blood being more exposed closer to
the surface of your skin such that you
can radiate more heat
yeah whereas you get vasoconstriction
when you're cold so that you know this
thing
is you know this basically you're the
radiator that's not most of what your
blood is doing but
it effectively is a radiator throughout
your body you want to keep that as close
to your core as possible when you don't
you don't want to lose heat and you want
to put that as close to your surface as
possible when you do want to lose heat
and so vasodilation and sweating tend to
go
in humans hand in hand yeah i think well
my guess is they always go
hand in hand yeah that it is exactly how
a radiator works
uh except that it's using evaporation
rather than
than uh wind to cool the fins the
radiator but
um well but that's that's the sweating
the the blood circulation isn't using
no but they're part and parcel the idea
is yeah but i think but they really are
different i don't think so i think this
works exactly like
a heat pump in a house and the basic
point
is the heat generated in your body is
carried by the blood to your surface it
is then
reduced in temperature by the
evaporation off your surface
which will be enhanced by any wind that
blows away the boundary layers because
if there's no wind let's say you were
sitting still
sweating then what would happen is you
would build up a
vapor boundary layer around you which
would reduce the rate of evaporation so
yes wetness just sits on your skin this
is why
for example um if you're working really
hard at high altitude
you know when we used to hang out in the
sierras right you're at high altitude
and you're hiking right except like
where your backpack is keeping the sweat
on your back
you tend to actually be pretty dry and
it's not that you're not sweating it's
the tendency for it to evaporate off
your surface is very very high
right right but that's not that's that's
wind but that's also the
right it's the dryness and the low
pressure
so anyway any of all of these things a
one of the things that
probably has a lot to say about who
sweats and who doesn't
is you know you've as you pointed out
fur is going to create a boundary layer
problem that makes sweating less
efficient
but there's also a question of whether
or not you can afford this mechanism in
order to cool yourself right
you would need access to water in order
to make it a
reasonable thing to do because you can
dehydrate from basically
sweating yeah i think also um the
turbinates the
you know these the the bones inside
especially the carnivores among mammals
the you know the the
phytogenic group that is the carnivores
they didn't have these big noses
and um would you like a prop sure
and you know we tend to think of that
because it's in the nose that's
entirely about smell and enhancing the
ability to smell and in fact
you know in fact it is let's see um
you can see in the side there all of oh
now there
um just heard i'm going to drop it on my
computer all of those bones inside the
nasal cavity
um are the turbinates and they provide
a tremendous amount there's a there's a
cat hair in there
um a tremendous amount of surface area
which and of course in the living animal
those are covered in
um in flesh which includes not just
sensory receptors in the form of smell
receptors
and so yes animals with big long noses
with lots of turbinate
turbinate bones on which to put lots of
those receptors do tend to smell better
they is there a way to make that clear
they smell
more effective they smell more
effectively than those with smaller
noses
but those turbinates also you know
covered in flesh
are vascularized which means they have
circulatory
vessels in them and so you'll get like
more rapid breathing as well when an
animal is hot
and that that's basically increasing air
flow across the um
across the vascular tissue across what
well i was going to add something i
think that's yeah no but okay so
so you weren't going to correct me but
like this this is just this is
absolutely true and not right not
new to anyone unfortunately i imagine
it's new to a lot of people
but um certainly um it is understood
that um the more
when animals get hotter if they have
more
nasal space they will tend to be
breathing faster shorter breaths and
that that is going to increase
the efficacy of shunting heat
out of the basically the circulatory
system out into the air
and in a parallel to something that we
talk about in the book which is the
difference in body shape between
dwellers
of very hot landscapes who tend to be
lanky in order to radiate heat and
dwellers of arctic landscapes who tend
to be rounder to preserve
heat the turbinates in
[Music]
mammals marine mammals in the arctic
actually have an elaborate counter
current exchange mechanism yes that's
right functions exactly the reverse of
what you were just saying which manages
to recapture heat that would otherwise
be lost to the environment based on the
direction of circulation
that's beautiful yeah so not a complete
evolutionary history for 50 bucks but i
think you guys
yeah yeah i mean you got to look at a
skull yeah there you go
um this is a little a little
heartbreaking but um
how can i go about being in a
relationship with my girlfriend who
shares a completely different stance on
vaccines coveted etc
i'm a 25 year old male and we don't know
it doesn't matter who's who right well
um
this one's easy isn't it oh i don't know
okay go for it i mean
look we're in this situation all day
every day
with all of the people who are
um decent and reasonable on this topic
which is that i mean frankly i've been
having discussions where
we talk about the situation of what the
evidence does and doesn't say
and nobody asks anybody whether they're
vaccinated because it's immaterial the
point is
the the we are united
in being interested in finding out what
is true
and it sometimes it's relevant that you
are or are not on one side of this but
basically look if you've got
a strong relationship then
you know look each other in the eye and
say i love you and
you know just recognize that this is not
a clear-cut situation reasonable people
find themselves on both sides of this
issue
the important thing is that you not
expose each other
to danger but needing to right but i
think
what you just said reasonable people can
find themselves on both sides of this
issue
or rather i think what you mean is that
there are reasonable people on both
sides of this issue
um the line that we are being fed by the
mainstream media
and by team blue is that that is not
true and so
if you are if you are in that camp you
are likely being told
that if you are in the other in the
other camp and i hate the
framing of it being two sides but um
then you can't be reasonable and you are
putting me at risk
and you're the enemy right and so you
know what what you just said
will will work but it may require like a
a
a d culting first um
yes and no i i mean look i hate to say
this
but there are certain discoveries about
another person
that will make it impossible to go
forward
if it is true that the person that you
are partnered with is going to find your
understanding of the evidence and
therefore your conclusion about your own
health and well-being to be
immoral if that's their position
then either they can be reasoned with
and get over it
or they can't in which case haven't you
just found out something
about the character of that person
i mean really we're talking about a
situation in which
the evidence is unclear and those who
claim it's clear
are clearly saying things that any
reasonable person
can understand are not sensible
that ought to cause us to give each
other a break
to the extent that somebody has the
opposite reaction to the extent that
somebody
finds themselves embracing
some authority's attempt to demonize
some fraction of the population that is
not convinced of their
safety in light of some piece of
advice that's very frightening and you
know i mean i
we've said it before there's something
terrifying about the fact that we now
hear public health authorities inducing
citizens
to declare some fraction of the
population
effectively unclean
and pathological and
right i don't think this makes any sense
for
if vaccine variants are the result
of selection in the vaccinated the
vaccinated are not at fault
right to the extent that vaccine hazards
showing up in the vares database cause
people to be
unwilling to expose themselves to
vaccination that doesn't mean that the
unvaccinated
are at fault it means whatever it is
that left us
with a signal in the vares database that
is frightening and that does not tell us
what that signal means or explain
anything about it
that thing is at fault and we've got to
stop going after each other right and
i really i my sense is
we're all in this together except people
who don't get that we're all in this
together
yep
there are a number of these i just don't
know what to say i moved across the
country right before covid for a good
job at a public university
and now fear that i will eventually be
fired for no jab
do you see the potential for class
action advice for that path
many thanks um
it's too early to know yes certainly
no advice um you know
there are going to be causes of action
in various places and then in other
places you're going to find that that
path has been blocked by legal obstacles
that have nothing to do with
you know your actual moral rights yep
that's right lex friedman and daniel
schmachtenberger talked about designing
social technology
sounds like a likely hobby of brett's
are there any social tech prototypes you
can unveil here
from the militant moderate well
um so you can certainly look up
game b game b is kind of a prototype of
prototypes
many of us who are involved in game b
see that game b is a concept meaning
game b is a replacement
for our current system that is
competitively superior to our current
system such that it displaces it rather
than having to win over hearts and minds
and lots of us who have seen that
as a foundational
insight or a a fork in our
social code are involved in one project
or another
that we hope produces some kind of game
b and frankly only one of them has to
work
so there is game b as the general
concept
and then we in our book uh begin
to describe something we call the fourth
frontier which is a
version of of a game b universe
and i don't know i i guess if you're
interested
i would tune into those kinds of
conversations daniel is a good place to
go
to and the more people we have
involved in thinking about what we might
do for the next phase of civilization
the more likely we come up with
something that's really
worthy of us indeed
observing possible ade slash
breakthrough and covet expression
assumption that the vax may be spreaders
to the faxed unvaxed
it appears that the vax degrades could
early vaxxed medical folks be vector of
spread variant to vax and unvaxed
um yeah i think this is this is what
we've been
talking about yeah very hard to follow
all the yeah
the twists and turns but i mean yeah i
again
we should not be pointing to individuals
um but
was a technology that was imperfect and
the policy that's
that uh introduced it um
pretty slowly throughout all the
populations where it was introduced
uh in conjunction likely to create the
selective pressure
to enhance the
to not produce new variants but
enhance uh new variants in terms of
their uh frequency in the population
uh yeah almost certainly
so this and this again this is um based
on
um really you know not just basic
evolutionary thinking which okay
you know a lot of vaccinologists and
virologists and such maybe don't have
any background in that although frankly
that's not okay you know vaccines are in
intentionally related to um
to evolution um i don't know
i'm just so frustrated by all of this
yeah it's very frustrating um
i would say there are two things implied
in the question which are distinct one
is the issue of variance and yes
people who have been vaccinated and have
a breakthrough case um
pose a danger not only to other
vaccinated people but to unvaccinated
people
and you know what we have been saying
which i think is
should be obvious is that there's an
interplay right it's not that the
unvaccinated play no role in that it's
not that the vaccinated play no role in
that there's an interplay between them
now there are other categories right
you've got within the unvaccinated
you've got
people who are naturally immune as far
as we know because they've had coven you
have people who have protected
themselves
with ivermectin the degree of protection
is going to depend on what protocol
they've used and it's going to depend on
things that we can't nail down precisely
yet because there's not enough
information
but i suspect excuse me i suspect that
the degree of protection
uh is going to hinge in part on the
presence of comorbidities
i've not seen that anywhere um
uh but you know the only the closest
thing i've seen i've been talking about
comorbidities for
a while now but is you know that that
the
deaths that really bad outcomes from
covet
are almost always in concert with
comorbidities and the more you have the
more likely that is to be true
but i suspect and i'd like to see some
data on this
um that actually contracting it at all
is um
is going to be more likely the if you
have comorbidities
could well be um but in addition to the
issue of
variance and who gets infected and who
is protected and by what mechanism
the other thing that is mentioned in
there is antibody dependent enhancement
which is a separate question and the
question we have seen
numerous cases in which there is a
phenomenon in which the immunity that
one has
to a given virus actually enhances that
virus's capacity to infect and harm that
individual
and we do not know that this is taking
place here it is quite plausible that it
could take place with respect to this
virus and so those who understand this
issue are looking for a signal for this
there are signals that could be
interpreted that way
it is not clear that they should be
interpreted that way so this is
this is a question on which many
people's fate hinges
but they don't know it so these two
things can go
i think we are seeing variants it's
quite clear that the vaccinated are
exerting a selective pressure on
uh the virus that is causing these um
variants to have enhanced fitness
right that is distinct from whether or
not the virus
infecting a person who has been uh
and by the way ade could happen um
through a natural path and it could
happen through a vaccine path
and the point is the antibodies
themselves would provide a mechanism for
the virus to infect cells it could not
otherwise access
and it's a very concerning phenomenon
but we shouldn't
leap to the conclusion that it is out
there we should just be very alert to
the possibility that is out there and we
should be very
careful not to be misled about that
hazard
um i don't know this study
barnstable massachusetts study said that
69
of the population was vast
um population facts i'm just trying to
understand the acronyms that think it
used
69 of the population was faxed pv
population faxed
and 74 of cases were from the vast
vaccinated cases if the vaccination
makes you less susceptible
shouldn't the population shouldn't the
proportion of the population that's
faxed be greater than the
portion of uh
cases that were from the facts shouldn't
pv
be greater than vc i'm trying to read
this so it makes sense to people while
also trying to make sure i get the math
right and translate this
um but in this case i mean these numbers
are really close 69 and 74 and without
knowing anything more about the numbers
we don't know if
um those numbers are actually close
enough to be essentially identical
we can't do statistics based on
percentages
but but yes like the logic is right here
um if if the vax makes you less
susceptible to the disease than you
would expect
um i think well
all else being equal
which is a condition certain not to be
met can we just say what the thing is
though
before before doing the caveats um
i think that all else being equal we
should expect that
if the vaccine makes you less
susceptible then the
population the percentage of the
population that is vaccinated
um should be
greater than the percentage of cases
that are among the vaccinated
i'm going to have to sit down with a
piece of paper to figure out what it is
but we could correct the numbers if you
had equal numbers of
vaccinated and non-vaccinated equal
percentage of the population and
the those two groups were
randomly chosen then you would expect a
smaller percentage of the vaccinated
population
to turn up positive given equal testing
now there are several
assumptions in there that are sure not
to be met which is how likely
are you to be tested yeah well and the
first thing
is you know especially given the rollout
anyway here
the u.s um the rollout was to people who
were at high risk first
right and so we have among the
vaccinated
more of the people who are at higher
risk of contracting
and having bad outcomes from the disease
therefore
um we might expect that in those
unfortunate people who are vaccinating
it
and um that they may be
simply continue to be more susceptible
than a person who was already healthier
um who got vaccinated as well but it's
not yeah
again it's not vaccinated versus
unvaccinated that there are these other
there's other characters that that
should should be brought in to predict
what the outcomes
would be and one thing that i think we
don't know
anything about i've never seen it
discussed
is what fraction of the quote-unquote
unvaccinated
are people who had covid
and therefore decided because their
cost-benefit ratio as they understood it
would have been different
may have decided in other words they
decided what not to be vaccinated
okay so if obviously if you had a
disproportionate number
of um naturally immune people
in the unvaccinated group that would
distort this calculation it would also
drive the percent uh vaccinated
uh the cases from vaccinated cases to
appear to be
higher than they are thus reducing the
signal of the effectiveness of the
vaccines
because in the unvaccinated camp are
people with actual real
immunity from having had coveted right
that's yeah that's true
so yeah so what you would want is you
would want
somebody to sample and figure out the
answers to these questions so that you
could correct for these biases so that
you could say
you know what are the percentages if we
exclude people who know that they have
or who strongly believe that they have
coveted because those people may have
made different decisions about vaccines
right yeah that kind of thing absolutely
that's good
um
adding to your [ __ ] you money stay
positive and keep up the good work
please
thank you yes we are nowhere near [ __ ]
you money we are at
no thank you money baby
we're not today um
in episode 88 you talked about aging
aging aging isn't a thing is it
ah not that i know aging and longevity
therefore i would like to know if you're
familiar with david sinclair's research
thoughts on
nmn and the concept aging equals lost
info on the epigenome when telomeres are
result not cause i know you've talked to
this before but
yeah um this puts me a little bit in
both russian and german
german this puts me in a little bit of
word of a weird spot because
in my long ago paper my 2002
paper that's when it was finally
published
i mentioned what if i had to do it over
again i would call
epigenetic entropy which i call
histological entropy
right it means the same thing it's a
loss of information from the systems
that tell tissues what
genes to transcribe in order to make
their phenotype
and so anyway i'm fond of the idea that
this is a an
epic an epigenetic failing
due to a breakdown in the information um
i am less hopeful than
sinclair about the utility of this
information
and its capacity to
engender therapies that will be
meaningfully useful in terms of
reversing this process
so maybe maybe that's it
um since people are no longer allowed to
be wrong online
and we're now banning misinformation can
we ban the media political complex for
its many lies and hoaxes
hold them to their own rules well
you know i mean this is i don't want to
get on another rant but you know i was
watching
biden tell people that if they get the
vaccine
they won't get coveted yeah right this
is
flat out misinformation coming from the
top
yeah right and the point is we just have
it's
asymmetrical it's so what seems to be
true
is that the vaccinated have a lower risk
of getting the disease um
[Music]
but that um that protection
begins fading pretty quickly pretty
quickly right um
so fully vaccinated isn't two weeks out
from your final shot into perpetuity
it's like fully vaccinated is like right
then and then you know a month later
you're a little bit less protected two
months later you know
this i mean i was i was shocked at the
point pfizer it's like oh six months
kind of not protected anymore you
probably need boosters six months six
months yeah well pretty damn short yeah
it's pretty damn short and the
protection is pretty damn narrow
yeah and so yeah this is you know this
is terrible because for one thing all
the people who got sorry but all the
people who got vaccinated
early who were able to get vaccinate
early in this um
like are not fully protected at this
point and we don't really know what that
means
we don't know what that means that could
mean a lot of things we don't know what
that means and we don't know
what happens you know what does your
third shot and your fourth shot
mean you're talking about you're talking
about an
immune system that is now primed by your
prior vaccinations
right it is that it is a different
immune system than the one
that your first vaccination encountered
you can't jab the same immune system
twice
yeah i think i regret that you said that
but it's pretty good i mean
yeah that's true right i think it's the
word
jab that throws me yeah so i don't i
don't like it either yeah i have the
sense that some
very clever marketing person came up
with this because it kind of feels
hip and edgy yeah yeah yeah yeah no
you're right right
yeah you can't shoot the same immune
system twice shoot yeah
i've never heard that before either well
it's the present tense of shot right
yeah you cannot uh
yeah it's not going to be as pithy no
anyway
um you can't piss off pith
off the same immune system
well you're kind of pissing off your
immune system
yeah um antagonizing it with a uh
a like a
why don't you it's like i don't know
when people end train dogs to attack by
having somebody with a suit of something
anyway i think we have now gone
completely off the rails on this
question
um
okay we'll go there next
i had i had the wrong setting set up in
my sub stack and so i've now got
like 1500 emails most of which are of no
no consequence whatsoever so um where
did you send it to
zach i don't see it
okay yeah yeah well then that's my
that's my website
address yeah um except
yeah there's a ton from
oh oh it's from it's from okay here we
go yep got it
oh that's why i couldn't find it came
from a different person this week and so
when i went searching for it
um anyway no matter um
your intelligence so this comes with a
graph which i don't know
if let me see
but i don't show anything yet zach
because i don't want to inadvertently
show any addresses or anything
the question is your intelligence and
ability to dissect complex topics made
us surprised at how easily you followed
the whole food narrative uncritically
an intriguing but simplistic hypothesis
that cannot agree with the attached
mortality data
similarly sam harris readily accepted an
accurate character use of your code
vaccine critiques
which aligned with his bias our podcast
still good media for exposing each
other's blind spots
that's a that's a mixture of things well
so you can show this just briefly this
is the data that they're showing is life
expectancy by age in england and wales
1700 2013.
um this is a graph based on
data that i don't i can't i have no idea
how it was generated
um our world and data is the source but
i have spent literally zero time with
this so
um i'm being asked to uncritically
accept a graph
as opposed to um having spent
time with a couple of papers that looked
over the data um
from i think the i think the references
to the mid victorian
um era diets that we were talking about
two episodes ago anything about what
that graph even purports to represent uh
just that life expectancy continues to
climb
um that that they're that they're you
know so the paper
in question that we were talking about i
think is what it's a reference to
was that from 1850 to 1880 uh in
england um that there were actually
um that that that lifespans were higher
and that people were healthier
and taller and i remember the paper and
all of this and
um you know this i
maybe doesn't suggest that um
you know but i guess we're gonna have to
look at it well but i mean i
can't even see it oh i see um you know
maybe but also the point of the paper
was
in part the climb
that we have seen to the extent that
there is one that's significant
and a big part of the argument in the
paper was there hasn't been a
significant
improvement was that we are basically
trading off one form of mortality for
another
uh and there were you know there were
data and arguments in that paper
and they were referencing other papers
which i looked at whereas this is a
graph based on i don't know
i don't know what and it makes no it
makes no assessment
about what the cause of death is and so
the argument um and you know and and
and it was based not on a on a whole
food diet but um
yeah we have we have decades of thinking
about diet and food and so there was
hardly an uncritical assessment there
yeah now what i want to i'm beginning to
understand what this graph is
sorry i'm beginning to understand what
this graph is and i want to know a lot
more about what it's graphing too
because to the extent that you have
things like
um accidents zack you should be showing
this while we're looking at it thank you
to the extent that you have accidents uh
or
even
i mean i guess bacteriological
disease is going to intervene here in
some way that
arguably counteracts the point that we
were making in that previous thing but i
think without knowing what the causes of
death are
here this may or may not have an
implication
yep all right zach if i may thank you
all right um next question so these are
just in all sorts of
interesting orders uh what i don't know
anything about this what do you know
about the covet 19 vaccine being
produced by medicago with the
assistance of glasgow no idea no
information at all um
i'm just going to scroll down try to
pick up some coded questions before we
move we only got 15 minutes left but
then we're going to try to get some that
aren't coveted here
how many people who got faxed and then
caught and then caught covid were given
a placebo and that they were protected
but
actually weren't i don't know any i mean
the trials
the trials that have trials some people
were given placebos
i believe um i mean not placebos
controls
um but i don't i've not heard
of this being a thing that's happening
the allegation that is
people uh after
um authorization were given placebos
yeah
that's that's brand new to me
um all right i can't imagine how that
would be
yeah i don't i don't see even i can't
even figure out what the incentives
would be to
to be doing that be malpractice yeah
um but of course there's a lot of that
um
oh so two questions here could you
address yuri diggins
uh right follow-up slide deck in
response to your critique i found this
new counter analysis quite compelling
and then another one apparently that's
referring to
um what he did on rebel wisdom
i haven't seen it um you know we just
spent a long time putting out a
long written analysis of what we
understand the data say and we're not
going to continue to engage
in frankly bad faith critiques from
actors who insist on trying to draw our
attention away from
all the important things that we're
trying to do i'm going to uh
i'm going to push back a little bit i
don't know that on what i just said yeah
i don't know that we know that degan is
involved in bad faith
i think he's being um
extremely reckless and he's also being a
total dick about it but he
probably believes what he's saying and
probably is motivated
in all of it by the belief that it's
about saving lives
so i would say bad faith requires that
he knows he's saying things that are
untrue rather than just being reckless
but what i don't get
is degen was thoroughly discredited
um
by the alexandros
thread and by our analysis
right this was nonsense right these
critiques were really low quality
they reported wrong things about what we
said
about what others said and concluded so
why
the scientific literature right so why
are we expected to respond repeatedly
yeah my sense is when somebody has been
as thoroughly discredited
as degen has been sorry we need
uh a better interlocutor before we're
expected to respond to it yeah we need
better skeptics
yeah um this is from
someone whom we respect a lot so i'm
gonna ask the question but i don't quite
understand it
okay is pedophilia
software based oh this is about human
software okay so it's pedophilia
software based
it seems to be used to break young
people's respect for themselves and
weaken their ability to resist
corruption um a tradition worth
enhancing in a totalitarian spirit
so i think i think what this is coming
from is like
is is this on the rise is like
people who are actually suggesting um
that this
you know should be one of the most
egregious things that people can
possibly engage in
being trotted out increasingly by those
who are saying yeah maybe you just
should accept this
it's completely reprehensible and
disgusting um
but it it does potentially
serve to break break
further break reality and
internal locus of control and uh
a moral sense uh that if
in whom in adults who are not involved
in this discussion just
seeing this discussion happening or i
think you know
you know frankly potentially everyone
but in any one of these cases as soon as
you
are forced to accede to something that
isn't
true or isn't right so the aced to
something that isn't true
men are women ah once you've said that
you're just like in a different spot
right once you've
once you've been forced into a position
that turns out wasn't the position you
thought it was
perhaps um you're in a different spot
and it's harder to get back to
um the position that you were in and
with regard to
to this once you have been forced to
entertain
the idea that you know and i've heard
people i respect and i've been
shocked to hear people i respect say oh
it's been said that pedophilia is just
in their sexual orientation like
no yeah no don't go there don't go there
that is horrifying well not go there
this is horrifying
because it psychologically
cripples people
it cripples them when they're children
and they carry it for life
so that is why this topic
is um permanently beyond what reasonable
people will entertain
yeah but with respect to the question i
still think the question
is too vague is pedophilia
software-based
i think we know that it is at least
partially software-based because we know
that people who have been abused as
children often go on to abuse
that suggests that it is an acquired
characteristic
i think what the person who asked the
question is asking is it
is the discussion of it amongst people
who presumably aren't
involved in it and that may well have
something to do
with authoritarianism yeah
arguably totalitarianism but i think the
basic point is yes this is
something we all agreed is completely
beyond the pale
until very recently where people have
been exploring
this question publicly as if there's
something to be discussed
and um you know i i don't know i know uh
james lindsay has pointed this out i
haven't followed closely his argument
here but
um but yeah i do i do think we are in
danger effectively of
watching things that we thought at least
we will never have to entertain that
question
we are now watching these questions
entertained in polite company
and that's a very dangerous sign about
where we are
yep um
how do you guys deal with high pressure
speaking events ted talk
joe rogan podcast any psychological
tricks advice
um so i mean you've done more of these
than i have but i think frankly getting
up and talking at length for hours on
end
in front of uh college students for 15
years
did it right it just yeah yeah
i mean so i think there are two things
um
as much as 25 or 50 or 75 college
students isn't the same as
you know an audience of millions but um
right but it works but it works it works
over time
um i would also say i used to tell
students that um
i have the sense that there's some the
number may very well be different for
each person but there's some
relatively small number of instances in
which you get up in front of an audience
and speak that you have to go through
before
it's in any way comfortable and let's
say it's 25 but most people
in their lifetime maybe get to
19 or 20. so they never get the sense
that actually okay you do kind of get
over that
right um so the answer is
what do you do you force yourself to
do it and then you figure out how to
evaluate it
without um you want to dwell just
exactly the right amount right you want
to stop
dwelling on your errors at the point
that it's no longer useful
yeah and it's i mean i if you had asked
me at 16 or 18 or 21
if i was going to end up comfortable and
actually enjoying
talking to people i would say no hell no
no way
no no way um but you start doing it
and uh and and that that's it right
there
and in fact that's part of why i always
um you know it's harder than more
students you have but
i tried to have students present at
least a couple of times during each
10-week quarter to everyone and that's
you know if you have a lot of students
that takes up a whole lot of class time
and it you know
it eats up it eats up some what else you
can do with the curriculum but
um just even getting up you know knowing
okay you've got five minutes
to tell everyone you know where you are
in this quarter long project
um and you know we're looking at
everything
and i'm going to be honest with you
right not you know
not just the content and your
conclusions but the design of the slides
and how you present and whether or not
you you know
looked some way that was drawing
attention to how you look as opposed to
what you were saying you know all of
these things
and um you know students who had
us over many quarters therefore just got
a lot of experience of getting up in
front of their peers and saying stuff
that uh was different from their
experience on social media for instance
yeah and it and it helps it does help
structural biochemistry after several
math challenges to darwinism recently
is there a way to save the theory of
evolution from the ash heap
could you repeat that structural
biochemist here
after several math challenges to
darwinism recently is there a way to
save the theory of evolution from the
ash heap
um yeah absolutely now i only think i
know what you're talking about
um but uh
so i've been arguing that there
is a problem with darwinism as it is
currently presented
this is leaving open the door to
challenges that darwin at darwinism
itself is
false but in fact the cure for these
things is the recognition that there is
a layer of darwinism that is not well
recognized
that explains the enhanced power
of darwinism to generate adaptation
so the way i've said this before is
the story in the bio 101 textbook that
you have random mutations
and selection which alters genes that
then results in the change in
form of creatures that turns a
shrew-like animal
into a bat that story can't be right
because the difference between
a shrew and a bat is not housed
in the shape of its proteins right
that's not to say proteins have no
impact on it but it's to say
that a random process that tried to turn
a shrew
into a bat by working at the molecular
level
in this way doesn't really add up right
the difference between
a motorcycle and a pickup truck is not
inherently chemical there are chemical
differences
but that's not where the information is
so what i've argued is that there's
something called
explorer modes and explorer modes which
are
we cover uh a pretty good introduction
to them in
in our book explorer modes are
mechanisms whereby
selection reduces the search space so
that the search is more efficient
for forms that are viable and
so the long and short of it is yes the
solution to the problem that you're
pointing to if it's the one i think
you're pointing to
is more in better darwinism it is not uh
to
consign darwin to the ash heap of
history because darwin wasn't wrong the
mistake that you're talking about
happened
after darwin okay we've got four minutes
there's four questions here that i
really want to get to okay let's see if
we can do it four minutes yeah um if we
take eight minutes maybe we'll
call it okay i think i think you'll
still catch your plane
we'll see which one of our senses
suffers the most for modern life
how to improve it so i'm going to spend
hours on this question
and i don't think we can do it quite so
quite so simply as
which one suffers the most but
my sense is that one so we are being
targeted on all of our senses by
by the modern environment and by
advertisers in particular
but maybe the one that is sort of
cryptically
the most affected i'm going to cheat
here the ones are the chemical senses
which is smell and taste and because we
are being gamed uh in our smell uh
by things like deodorants and uh and
um perfumes
okay but specifically the odors being
put into products that would otherwise
smell incredibly foul because
of what it takes to make them and so you
have these
synthetic odors that nominally smell
good to cover the foulness
that means that we cannot use as we
alluded to before we cannot use our
sense of smell as we used to be able to
use it
to drive us towards healthier
actions and the same thing with taste
we're having
our long ago
selection for sweet and for umami and
for salt
gamed by the ability to cheaply and
quickly add them to processed foods such
that those things
that taste good aren't any more those
things that are rare or good for us
anything yeah i would just say all of
them are worst affected
maybe if i had to break one out i would
actually say
it's the the ability the sound the
ability to hear things that there's so
much in our environments you are so
constantly filtering out the noise
whether it's the hum of light bulbs or
you know cars on the highway that
you know next time you're somewhere
where you can't hear any of those things
and it is actually pretty hard to get to
where you can't hear any of those things
but next time you're somewhere that you
really can't hear any of them
take a moment to listen right it's a
very different planet
so we've already failed to do this in
anything like short but um
i'm reminded of the last time um that we
were in the amazon
in january 2020 um
and it's super super remote super deep
there's no roads
um but some number of miles away even
though
super deep super remote all of this um
is
unfortunately a new um oil
oil platform oil oil platform and we
were on this oxbow lake
looking at watson at one point and we
just
suddenly heard the sound of machinery
and in part because
it's so flat and there's so much less
else that you were hearing
we could hear whatever had ramped up the
generator or something
yeah from many miles away this is like
an oil platform
in the middle of this extraordinarily
large expansive you know
wireless diverse habitat on our most
diverse habitat on earth
uh and there it was yeah i am a white
male us high school biology teacher
in an urban predominantly black area
critical race theory is encroaching here
how can i battle this to ensure the best
education for
best education for my students
it's possible you know what actually i'm
gonna i'm gonna see if this i'm going to
forward that question the next session
so that we do it a little bit more
okay um so we're going to get we're
going to see that one next one so we're
going to just answer two more here
um thoughts on quercetin it's an easy to
find supplement that is a zinc ionophore
by chance we were just talking about
this this week
in general we are a fan of getting what
you need through your diet rather than
through supplements but in
an era of pandemics there are
things that you can use that are useful
c and d and zinc being
being among them and yes zinc is often
not bioavailable in the forms
that we take it in especially when not
as part of your diet and yes quercetin
seems to be
a thing that facilitates the uptake of
zinc yeah
i think there are things that seem to be
low cost and have the potential to be
useful and it's very hard to know when
you take them whether they're doing
anything for you right
and finally if you had to choose one
type of domestic animal to live with
what would it be and why
um it's a little hard to answer that
question here with the
kitty cat sitting on the table um
well i will say this i think this is a
question on which we might actually end
up having different answers that's why i
asked it um i actually
prefer two different creatures for two
different things
um i prefer
hanging out with uh kitty cats they're
very
um uh yes perfect
good um they're very uh
lovely company and they're also utterly
fascinating to think about what they're
thinking
and i prefer to do stuff with the dog if
you're gonna go
you know the dog can keep up with you on
your bike and can go for a hike with you
and loves to go to the river and swim
and so anyway it's
i think it divides for me between you
know you're cheating
that's awesome i mean i agree with you i
think most people who like both
would maybe they wouldn't have that
framing but yeah i do we've talked about
this a lot
i grew up with dogs not cats but i'm
really not a one or the other person i
really appreciate both species for
different things you
yeah i i i agree with all that i grew up
uh my brother had a dog but i
i had a cat earlier so i grew up with
cats and we had two for a little while
um but yeah if i actually absolutely had
to choose i would choose cats
all right yeah i said it you did you
said it you won't but
okay and he didn't know what you said no
he doesn't and whereas if maddie was in
the room if a dog was in the room she'd
be
she'd be crushed no
[Music]
she'd love me just as that's that's why
yes
she'd love me just as much no matter
what and uh i don't i don't understand
i don't understand there's nothing you
can do as long as you're decent to your
dog
that changes how they feel about you
very marvelous people
they are all right um well i think we've
reached the end because uh you gotta
like
throw your stuff in a bag and get on a
plane go um
we uh let's see i've already closed my
notes uh notes for the day
we join our patreons please
and um consider uh becoming a free
subscriber at my new
sub stack which is
naturalselections.substack.com
you'll get an email with each new post
every tuesday and sometimes more often
than that
[Music]
um there is a tip jar on odyssey that
you can use
to give us tips in libraries blockchain
or fiat
american dollars currency uh you can get
our new goliath t-shirts at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org if it doesn't
have the words on the back it's not the
real thing
right um email questions logistical
questions like hey
i have we got a box of mangoes this week
from
a fan who grows mangoes they were
fabulous they are fabulous we just
picked them up yesterday
and that person knew where to send them
by asking darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
for the address of our we have a po box
and an address for po box where you can
send packages
and we ask that you if you if you are
willing to subscribe to all four
of our channels the two on youtube brett
weinstein's main one
and dark course podcast clips and the
two similarly named ones
identically named ones i think on
odyssey
anything else to say um i don't think so
i think it's time to close out with with
be good to the ones you love and get
outside no
wow i screwed it up go to the ones you
love and eat good food and get
outside be well everybody
you